in ribbons um it's quite a dramatic
sight um the fire the fight london fire
brigade said they were called at about
uh called to the scene at about 1 30
this afternoon um for a partial collapse
of the roof they said um
there are a thousand people evacuated
but no reports of any injuries and they
have now made the scene safe
and say there's no structural damage to
the building the o2 have also sent us a
statement they said that due to today's
adverse weather conditions we can
confirm there has been some damage
caused to the tent fabric in our roof at
the o2 the affected areas have been
cleared and the o2 will remain closed
for the rest of the day the safety of
our visitors remains of paramount
importance and we will continue to
assess the ongoing situation and act
accordingly now there was due to be um a
concert tonight the fugees 25th
anniversary tour that has of course been
cancelled but it just shows you exactly
why there has been this unprecedented
red red weather warning in london
because of the strength of those wings
which means there's not just a risk to
damage a risk of damage to property and
disruption but a risk to life as well
and two people in london have actually
been taken to hospital after being hit
by debris as well so it is incredibly
serious what these winds can do and we
will stay across it for the rest of the
afternoon as it passes through london